in today's money watch we're focusing on
how to avoid financial scams the irs
recently shared its list of top scams to
watch out for this year some of the
biggest involved stimulus payments and
tax refunds where scammers pose as irs
agents and try to get your bank and
personal information the irs also warns
taxpayers to watch out for fake charity
scams last year check this out americans
lost more than 5.8 billion with a b
billion dollars to fraud cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger is
here to help us out because we need it
so jill what's the biggest red flags
that people should look out for you know
the irs is very clear they don't call
you they don't text you they don't reach
you through social media they generally
i would say 99 of the time they're
sending you a letter through snail mail
saying hey you owe us some money and
they give you a chance to respond to
that but the reality is if you're
getting a call a text an email you need
to just have your guard up and you think
it's from the irs the other thing is the
irs is not calling you and saying we
demand payment send us a gift card the
irs is not saying give us this debit
card information and the irs most
clearly is never asking for your
personal information best thing to do is
just delete it get rid of it don't
answer the phone if you don't know who
is calling sometimes that fear though
people lean right into it because they
don't know you mentioned email tell us
about this realistic email that people
should watch out for i think the
fraudsters are getting quite adept at
looking at logos and saying maybe they
take this from the irs logo you get a
logo it looks like it's coming from the
irs and then there's a demand to action
or a must act now and you can imagine if
you're not really attuned to this you
say oh the irs is sending me an email
it looks like this it looks like i need
to do something let me give them the
information they need and so people are
just opening up and sometimes they have
a bit of information already about you
so let's say this is your uh address
could you just correspond your social
security so that's how they get you with
a little bit of information that
identifies with you they're like oh this
must be official exactly right okay so
most people when they think of scams
they think oh it's just older people
that aren't really hyped to the internet
and they don't know how to use their
phones or email but 41
of people in their 20s were scammed last
year so young people are falling for
these tricks as well absolutely well i
mean it is emotional so what is a
scammer doing a scammer is sort of
leaning into your fear or your greed
right so on the fear base if i'm 25
years old and i get something and it
says you owe us money we're from the irs
you're like oh oh my god i got to do
something and so when you feel like that
your emotion is heightened you're more
likely to give over information think
about the general scams that are out
there they really do lean into the fear
base like you owe us something or it
could be the greed base hey you you're
missing a stimulus payment and sometimes
it tugs at your heartstrings hey those
poor people in ukraine give us money and
the charity that it comes from you think
it looks like a legitimate charity it's
not so just have your guard up it's kind
of like defensive driving like you got
to have your guard up yeah okay so tell
us about um cryptocurrency because it's
it's a it's a buzz word and people hear
crypto and they think i need to get rich
yes and i think that's the greed part
it's amazing so when you think about it
crypto is this great combination for
scammers because it's volatile so it's
gone way up goes way down oh get in on
it it also has a lack of clarity like
what is this thing so the layer of
mystery how it all works exactly and so
if i'm confused i'm like yeah maybe i do
need to do that so we really want people
to be careful a billion dollars lost to
crypto fraud um last year and through
the first three months of this year and
those frauds can be you know it can be
something as awful as like a boyfriend
girlfriend saying hey pay me in crypto
do this but it's usually a get rich
quick scheme so remember when you're
investing of course any solicitation if
it seems too good to be true it probably
is too good to be true thank you so you
go from dollar dollar jail to keep it
real jill yeah valuable information joe
slesner thank you so much